[Música]
al otro lado de la frontera sudanesa en
el vecino Chad los refugiados se reúnen
para recibir ayuda humanitaria el propio
Sudán acaba de recibir su primer envío
de ayuda 8 toneladas de suministros
médicos transportados por vía aérea a
Puerto Sudán desde Jordania en una
operación organizada por la Cruz Roja
realmente esperamos que esto se
convierta ya saben en parte de un
mecanismo de coordinación estable para
permitir que lleguen otros vuelos
tenemos otro equipo listo otro
contingente médico listo para ser
transportado en avión la Sudán Y de
nuevo esperamos obtener las
autorizaciones adecuadas con las
garantías de seguridad adecuadas para
entregar esto a los hospitales
mientras los combates continúan en Sudán
a pesar de las treguas declaradas los
hospitales se están quedando sin casi
todo lo que necesitan aquí cerca de
Cartoon se están racionando los
medicamentos críticos tras comprobar
nuestros suministros y Consultar con el
personal responsable de las reservas
médicas Hemos llegado a la conclusión de
que la situación actual no puede
mantenerse durante más de una semana es
un problema enorme la Organización
Mundial de la Salud hace sonar la alarma
ante una catástrofe inminente incluso
antes de la guerra Sudán dependía en
gran medida de la ayuda internacional
Mientras tanto las Naciones Unidas
envían a la región a su principal
coordinador de ayuda de emergencia para
supervisar la respuesta de la ONU a lo
que denomina una crisis humanitaria que
se deteriora rápidamente